ça y est c'est acté la fusion psa fiat
chrysler a été approuvé et le groupe
sera baptisé c'est l'anti c'est contre 1
400 mille salariés dans le monde est
cette synergie regroupera 14 marques
automobiles dont citroën maserati opel
alfa romeo ou encore jeep
une fusion qui se chiffre à près de 45
milliards d'euros d'après la valeur des
deux groupes en bourse lestée lantiss
devient donc le quatrième groupe
automobile mondial
il produira 9 millions de véhicules et
sera dirigé par carlos tavares et cette
alliance elle a du bon puisque grâce à
elle psa et fiat chrysler vont pouvoir
réduire leurs coûts de production et
améliorer leurs offres pour rattraper
les pertes liées à la crise sanitaire
les deux groupes respectifs profiteront
mutuellement de cette union pour
renforcer leur présence en europe quant
au groupe français et bien ce sera
l'occasion de plébisciter le marché
américain
finalement c'est une alliance profitable
qui leur permettraient et d'économiser
cinq milliards d'euros par an
sauf que cette fusion est bien l
inquiète les syndicats de psa
quel sera son impact sur les emplois
dans les usines françaises
la direction de psa la garantie il n'y
aura pas de fermeture de site mais
quelques exemples passés de fusion
industriel incite à la prudence
on se souvient notamment des engagements
de l'américain general electric qui lors
de l'acquisition des activités énergie
d'alstom en 2014 s'était engagé à créer
1000 emplois en france quatre ans pour
finalement s'apprêter à supprimer 750
emplois
pour en avoir le coeur net il va falloir
être patient mais les syndicats échaudés
attente aujourd'hui toast elantis
s'engagent à ne pas fermer d'usiné
mettant en péril des milliers d'emplois
déjà fragilisées par la crise sanitaire